that's the reason why that gym culture
don't work you like I was just this I'll
just say how does how does Zoom culture
not work it doesn't work like I was
saying okay let me talk about what
outcome so so I'm guessing Zim is more
traditional right very okay okay so so
it's like the woman submits to the her
husband right whether she's she's
cheating on you or not whether he's
abusing or not you stay women are
happier in traditional outcomes every
stat will tell you this women have more
STDs they're more likely to be depressed
they're more likely to be on
antidepressants they're more likely to
have had an abortion in a more 50 50
modern society in traditional countries
operate in traditional outcomes the
women are happier